Since the advent of computers, designing
complex machines and structures has
become way easier.
Computerized topology optimization can
simplify components of these modern
marvels even further
reducing weight and increasing efficiency.
But there's a limit. Object sizes can't be very large.
Researchers at the Technical University
of Denmark have created a new software
tool that can visualize and optimize
complex shapes in high resolution.
Just as images on a computer screen are
broken up into pixels, 3D images are made
up of boxes called voxels.
Previous computer design tools for this kind of
engineering could only generate designs
that were about 5 million voxels large
but with the giga voxel resolution of
the new system objects can be made up of
over 1 billion voxels.
So huge or highly detailed objects can be optimized.
The researchers say that their system scales
in both directions.
It can help optimize massive engineering projects and smaller nanoscale technologies.
The engineers put the system through its paces
by feeding it a 27 meter long wing from a technical
model that resembles a Boeing 777
airliner.
A supercomputer crunched the
numbers for five days and produce a new
design.
A wing with a radical internal structure that is kept solid
through curved wing spars and diagonal ribs.
The new, more hollow wing weighs 5% less than the current wings in use on the Boeing 777.
Such a reduction in weight means
the plane would consume up to 200 metric
tons less fuel per year.
But the wing itself cannot be reasonably assembled
through any modern production process.
However the researchers were able to
successfully 3D print a section of the wing.
And new methods of additive manufacturing
could make fabricating these designs easier in the future